Welcome to Module One — an introduction to deep learning and TensorFlow.
In the next minute: what deep learning actually is, why it took over machine learning this decade, and the three ideas it all rests on — representations, the chain rule, and gradient descent.
The big shift that started it all: moving from hand-crafted features to learned ones.
A deep network is just a stack of differentiable functions.
Its power comes from composition — not one clever layer.
Training means minimizing a single loss with gradient descent, and gradients flow backward through the chain rule.
So why did all of this happen now?
Three things converged: AlexNet on ImageNet in twenty-twelve halved error rates, GPUs unlocked massive training, and tricks like ReLU and batch norm made depth stable — all wrapped in open-source frameworks.
The stack you'll use for that is TensorFlow and Keras.
Tensors are arrays that live on CPU or GPU.
T-F-dot-function compiles your Python into a graph.
Keras is the high-level API most courses teach.
And GradientTape handles differentiation when you write your own custom loops.
Here's gradient descent in thirty seconds.
Pick a loss that measures how wrong you are.
Compute its gradient with respect to the parameters.
Step against that gradient.
Repeat on mini-batches until the loss plateaus — and everything else in this course is variance reduction on that one loop.
Here's the road ahead.
Ten modules — fundamentals, CNNs, advanced training, segmentation, detection, GANs, NLP, time series, and production.
Each has theory, hands-on labs, and a quiz.
And your progress stays on your device.
Let's get started — open the first lab.